before we go on further with this topic
we never really got to the presidential
campaign last week and Donald Trump
entered and I just want it we never
really discussed it and I have to say I
want to ask you to especially because I
hear all over the media he's just a joke
it's just it's just a publicity stunt
don't worry about it it'll go away
it's not going away let me tell you so
now this is the Frankenstein monster
that was created with the Tea Party this
is your worst nightmare because he's
catapult to second in the polls and by
the way he's pissed about that he thinks
he should what it's I I don't think the
dog can say at the poll stay on top of
the polls right there I do I really
don't think he makes everybody else look
like a not in a good way but at
you know what like here here here's the
thing about Donald Trump
he never apologizes he's never wrong
matter what crazy thing he says he's
totally but he's the white Kanye
was a reality for a part that was bass
adores belligerence this is the guy I
mean last girl I gotta go I don't think
it'll last but I think the belligerents
point is true and that and that people
are responding to this thing that they
find refreshing about him where he just
says this guy sucks and this guy sucks
and he doesn't apologize for people but
I think people are looking for
politicians that will say you know they
they clearly are saying something that
it looks like they believe I think the
problem that that Donald Trump is cool
among the many problems the Donald Trump
is going to have is that I think he I
mean he is viewed unfavorably by almost
three-quarters of people who are
Republicans now that one quarter that
thinks favorably of them they may be
that 11% that says the vote for his
whole yeah but these are his ideas are
not as effective I mean Donald the scary
thing about Donald Trump is not his
views reflect what millions are on
millions of people in the Republican
Party enough so Donald Trump in recent
weeks has started to kind of become this
voice of white working-class angst
around things like trade and the
billionaire guy but that's not just for
Republicans I mean think about this
trade victory that we were talking about
how Obama said this great week around
trade the biggest opposition to what he
wanted to do on trade was coming from
the left from kind of what the populist
left so this is not just Donald Trump
pushing Republican buttons he's could
it's bizarre to me or not these boys of
white whale ass Americans yeah what now
what about what folks on this stage are
forgetting and conservatives are
forgetting is that he's a Hillary
Clinton donor he's from anti-gun
pro-choice and Pro
so no but if you said a mother as you
said if you set him up as the voice of
conservative America well conservative
note that these are also quite and
associate rights as beyond liberal or
conservative it's the end it's the
lighter afraid that this guy told he
said I'm gonna make the Mexicans behave
and he called them play
that little yeah this is even Rizzo play
it again they didn't hear it listen you
what listen to me you yes
but isn't this just a promotion for
Celebrity Apprentice
I mean RINO
you know who's getting money like do you
think people donate money to him like
he's a real candidate Jody's got worth
$9 says he's worth 9 he's a struggling
actor from Queens yeah was actually
worth negative $400,000 was that sweet a
pledge to do great the greatest the
greatest strong a greatest trick the
devil pulled office make people
disbelieve that he was real so the point
is the Donald Trump I'm not saying he's
the devil but you said it I D IOT and
the reality is that dot but but Donald
Trump is no idiot in this sense he
understands how to work his audience he
understands how to be not wrong but
right and his failure to apologize is
the kind of the kind of John Wayne
persona that George W Bush had and that
kind of swagger is what so much of those
people are looking for I'm telling you
when something odd about the age with on
the other nine people do you know Cour
that he doesn't pick on them next I
think they're afraid of Tommy oh I oh I
I think they're very afraid if you read
a State Fair and they and and you were
watching you know the corndog show or
something and somebody ran in and said
any of the other Republican candidates
showed up hey Rand Paul's here okay you
know like Carly Fiorina just showed up
yeah would you go Donald Trump just
showed up
what's because this is this is one where
I just indict the media on this one
because every time he does anything
loony he gets so so so much press
he holds a press release to be the
birther in chief and everybody goes and
watches him and then they point and said
how did he get it coming in second to
Jeb Bush both in New Hampshire and in a
new national poll I mean the point is
he's second among all of that gaggle of
people you have running but we also
watched we also watched we also watched
every member of the gaggle last time
rise and fall and I think we'll see that
yeah I don't think he's gonna be
President
can't hit like 1% but if he dreams he's
as a technical talent is Kanye he better
wake up and apologize yes
has been both is the most important
quality for running for president which
is thinking you're awesome enough to
write well that right right I would love
to see a trump Christie ticket and all
East Coast all you forget about
forget about it you know what he is a
guy on The Bachelorette that you don't
want kicked off the show yeah killer guy
you know he's a jackass if you're like
oh why they kick him off but we've been
great if he was there the whole time